in criminal investigations that's 87 of
which were assembled using products sold
by defendant polymer 80.
increasingly ghost guns have been
recovered in cases of homicide domestic
violence robbery and other violent
crimes
because they are unserialized as is
required by state law and therefore
untraceable by our law enforcement to
their original purchaser they can be
used to commit multiple crimes and have
become popular among illegal gun
traffickers
the lawsuit filed today against these
Distributors will hold them accountable
for the harm they've caused in our city
due to their Reckless and illegal
business practices and to stop them from
continuing to sell their illegal
products
I'm grateful to be joined today by our
city partners
assessment we will continue to fight for
every resident's right to health and
safety in their neighborhood with every
resource at our disposal
we're also joined today by the Giffords
Law Center to prevent gun violence which
provided extensive research and Analysis
to support our legal argument in the
lawsuit they will be speaking today
about how ghost guns are impacting
Philadelphia our Commonwealth and the
rest of the country but first I would
like to introduce our mayor Jim Kenney
his administration has shown great
dedication to combat to combating gun
violence through every possible Avenue
we are proud to announce This legal
action today in accordance with the
administrations and the city's priority
to make Philadelphia a safer place for
All City residents Mr Mayor
well good afternoon
thank you over the last three years we
have witnessed an explosion in gun
violence Across America and here at home
in Philadelphia time and time again
families have suffered the Heartbreak of
a murder loved one a son daughter a
father a mother or a friend and then and
in a horrific incident on Monday night
we all know a shooter murdered five
people and likely would have harmed even
more had the police not bravely and
swiftly apprehended the subject
as a city we all have endured these
tragedies together while investing
hundreds of millions of dollars to
address the problem
I want the public to know there is no
greater priority for our Administration
than to reduce violence and create safer
communities and a more just City for
everyone and we know that investing in
prevention and law enforcement has to be
part of that solution but make no
mistake the root of the problem is the
proliferation of guns in our city and in
our country guns are the common
denominator in every single shooting
this includes the illegal handguns known
as ghost guns and we are announcing the
filing of this lawsuit to stop them from
continuing the flood the streets of our
city
let's be clear about what we're doing
today and why
selling of ghost guns is using the mail
to sell a weapon that will often be used
in the commission of crimes and even
murder and we intend to stop it a ghost
gun is built by the manufacturer and
mailed in Parks or kits which are then
often assembled by the purchaser and
often used on the Streets of
Philadelphia to commit violent crime
these weapons are virtually untraceable
because they have no serial number and
they can be purchased without background
check which means anyone a criminal a
child anyone can buy a ghost gun it also
means that they are manufactured and
sold in violation of Pennsylvania Law
they're already illegal in the state
the manufacturers attempted to avoid
liability by claiming that it is selling
Parts not guns but the gun kits they
sell can be assembled in minutes by
virtually anyone all they need are
simple household tools
in Philadelphia our police department
has seen over a 300 percent increase in
the number of ghost guns in the last
four years which corresponds to the rise
in violent crime on our streets we've
made numerous joint calls for gun safety
and legislation that can help us do more
to protect our communities while
lawmakers have not answered any of these
requests as a matter of fact they've
stood in our way and and superseded many
of the things we've tried to do our
officers have taken a record number of
guns off our street let me reiterate our
Police Department is one of the finest
in the nation they're brave men and
women they put their life on the line
every day that incident on Monday night
they were taking active fire while
scooping people into cars getting into
the hospital to try to save their lives
and they they deserve all of our thanks
and credits so thank you
last year alone Philadelphia police
recovered 575 ghost guns in the course
of their criminal investigations and we
are not alone in the last four years the
use of ghost guns has exploded in cities
all across America
here in Philadelphia we hold criminals
accountable for their crimes that's
exactly what we're doing today the
manufacturer of these weapons need it
need to be held accountable for what
they're doing people are dying murdered
by weapons that are sold for the exact
purpose
if we as a city are serious about ending
gun violence then suing the
manufacturers of these weapons is a
critical Next Step
I commend our Law Department of the
police department and all those who have
worked to build the case for the lawsuit
we have filed today let this be a
warning to these manufacturers we are
coming and we will not stop until these
weapons are eliminated from our streets
so I'm now pleased to introduce my
colleague and our partner on this
ongoing fight to reduce the flow of guns
into our city city council president
Daryl Clark
good afternoon
um today we stand here one more time
doing what we shouldn't have to do
taking a route that we shouldn't have to
take because of the unwillingness the
lack of Courage of legislators on the
state side
and on the federal side right we
shouldn't have to do this but I want to
commend the mayor the solicitor the
Gifford Law Center the police all of the
people that are involved in this process
because you continue to come up with
creative ways to attack this very very
challenging problem so I commend the
heck out of you thank you so much for
always making sure that we're going to
try to keep our citizens safe
but I I just want to take a step back so
yesterday
Fourth of July Independence Day
celebrating freedom freedom of the
nation right and I saw and I'm sure a
number of you saw individuals marching
in parades with flags right those same
individuals that don't have the courage
to do the right thing right and pass
laws outline outlawing assault weapons
right
but why they marched and they talk about
Freedom the people in the neighborhoods
in King session and neighborhoods across
the city they don't have the freedom to
walk to the store at night because some
idiot has a gun and he's out there
shooting randomly
they don't have the freedom to go to
school right without worrying about
getting shot they don't have the freedom
to drive their car without worrying
about somebody putting a gun to their
head and saying give me your car right
so if they're going to be engaged in
this whole thing called Freedom which is
so important in our nation get engaged
in something and meaningful that the
overwhelming number of the people in the
country
get rid of assault weapons stop ghost
guns stop appealing the serialization of
ghost guns I mean these things are good
sense legislation and Regulatory and
issues so I don't know what it's going
to take for children getting shot mass
murders I think we're over like 350 now
in the city in the country
um what more will it take so for all
those individuals that want to celebrate
freedom
um and shot and shaking hands and
smiling and grinning for political
purposes step to the plate and do the
right thing and pass legislation so the
mayor city solicitor Gifford Law Center
guys I want to thank you so much to the
police we are we're here with you we're
going to make sure that we always
support you because we know you have our
back and you run to the fire right as
opposed to running away so thank you
look forward to continuing this awesome
awesome case uh very creative thank you
thank you all God bless you and please
be safe out there thank you
[Applause]
council president and Mr Mayor so
nationally the number of ghost guns
recovered by law enforcement has
exploded in recent years and accelerated
during the pandemic I'd like to
introduce David Pacino deputy chief
counsel at the Giffords Law Center who
will highlight the impact of ghost guns
and the efforts to stop their
distribution across the country David
thank you very much solicitor I Am David
Pacino I'm the deputy chief counsel of
Giffords Law Center to prevent gun
violence which is the gun violence
prevention organization founded and led
by former congresswoman and gun violent
Survivor Gabby Giffords my colleagues
and I at Gifford's Law Center we work
across the country to try to reduce the
number of injuries and deaths from guns
and in doing that work I've learned a
simple thing
that is that when people who should not
have guns who are not legally allowed to
have guns somehow get access to them
that's when people get shot and that's
when people get killed and so my
colleagues work every day to try to stop
that to try to prevent people who should
not have guns from getting their hands
on them and that is hard work but it's
made harder because there is an entire
industry that is focused on doing the
exact opposite and trying to get as many
guns out there on the street no matter
whose hands they go into no matter
whether their customers are legally
allowed to possess them or not
polymer 80 and jst Supply are focused on
a competitive Advantage which is that
they don't follow the gun laws that all
the other responsible gun dealers do
follow they don't conduct background
checks before they sell all their
products which is what a responsible gun
dealer would do and what is required by
law so when they're making a sale they
don't know who the purchaser is they
don't know if this person has a history
of felonies it could be at risk of
suicide could be a child could be a gun
trafficker they have no idea because it
doesn't matter to them what matters to
them is making the sale what matters to
them is the bottom line and that's not
just morally wrong it's a violation of
Pennsylvania Law so I'm proud to be able
to stand with the city today along with
the house fell Law Firm to be able to
say that this is going to stop that we
will not accept this unlawful and
Reckless conduct and we will not let
these companies mortgage our community's
safety for their bottom line thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much David and the
Gifford Law Center
so since the start of 2023 190
individuals including children have lost
their lives to gun violence an
additional 754 people have been shot and
seriously injured the gun violence
epidemic in Philadelphia is a serious
threat to the health of the public I'd
like to welcome Dr Cheryl bettergo our
health commissioner whose team has
witnessed the impact of ghost guns in
our communities firsthand Dr Medical
good afternoon everyone and thank you
for being here
when we think about what it means to
take a public health approach to gun
violence it's useful to think about how
that public health approach has improved
Auto Safety
over the past several decades a public
health approach focusing on identifying
risk factors and protective factors for
traffic deaths has led to safety
improvements to Road design car design
and to laws that govern driver Behavior
our highways are now built with Edge and
Center Line stripes and reflectors to
help drivers see curves improved
lighting addition of barriers separating
oncoming traffic lanes and with guard
rails
cars are now built with safety features
that we really take for granted now
including headrests energy absorbing
steering wheels shatter resistant
windshields and seat belts
and safer driver behavior is encouraged
through education and enforce through
laws against driving while intoxicated
and underage drinking and enforcement of
seat belt and child seat safety laws
drivers who persist in flouting these
laws by drinking and driving repeatedly
can lose their licenses to help keep all
of us safer
those changes have made an impressive
difference in traffic deaths per mile
driven
when we look at gun violence as a public
health problem we can take that problem
apart in a similar way to look at the
environment the gun itself and the gun
user
our state and federal gun laws recognize
the fact that most gun crimes are
committed by a few individuals and that
we can recognize the highest risk
individuals through their past actions
that is the reason that people who have
a history of a felony conviction for
committing a violent crime for instance
are barred from purchasing a gun as are
individuals who are the subject of an
act of protection from abuse order that
provides for the relinquishment of
firearms
background checks are required in the
state of Pennsylvania to identify
exactly this group of highest risk
individuals and to prevent them from
purchasing a gun
by supplying guns without the background
checks required by state law polymer 80
Inc and jsd Supply are making it easy
for high-risk individuals with a history
of violent acts and Firearm offenses to
obtain guns
in doing so they are putting all
philadelphians at risk
more than 200 Philadelphia children have
been shot in a single year and children
across the city report being afraid to
walk outside their homes
I am grateful for the actions of the
city of Philadelphia to put a stop to
the efforts of those ghost gun
manufacturers to do an end run around
Pennsylvania laws intended to keep guns
out of the hands of high-risk
individuals thank you all
[Applause]
we will take some questions now however
I would like to make sure that we talk
ask questions first about the lawsuit
before we get into anything else so
far
well we're just looking for sanity we're
looking for them to abide by state law I
mean Pennsylvania state law is weak one
of the weakest in the nation to start
with these guys go around even that so
what we're looking to do is to change
behavior and if they're going to
continue selling this deadly product
then they're going to have to follow the
same rules as other
like for one of a better word mainstream
uh gun dealers
um so I I'll you can talk about any
monetary settlement I just want them to
stop their behavior or put them out of
business
because we have a great Law Department
and um but but we don't listen
everything we've tried to do since I've
been here and before I've been here the
legislature has over Road us
intentionally the Republicans for the
most part and some conservative
Democrats have overrode every single
Common Sense thing we try to do we're
and we keep on coming up with hopefully
ingenious ways of attacking it but but
we can't just sit idly by I mean you
don't you've don't hold your breath for
the legislature or Congress to change
anything you'll turn blue uh because
they're not doing anything and and it's
we are we are the ones they are the ones
picking up the Carnage in the streets
and our families are the ones that are
suffering and traumatized and they're
taking checks in the NRA still hey great
let's have a party but they're not doing
their jobs and and I'm standing in the
courtyard of Independence Hall yesterday
for our celebration I thought to myself
after Monday night
people in that building who wrote that
document did not have this in mind they
wrote the Second Amendment for a single
shot muzzle loaded long gun that was
used to fight the British
because we had a militia now we have an
army navy Air Force Marine Corps and
Coast Guard we don't need a militia no
one needs to have an AR-15 they're not
defending anybody they're going out in
the street and killing people so we hope
to be successful we have to have some
change in their behavior and then if you
want to talk about any monetary I wasn't
aware of any monetary requests
and I'm sorry I didn't get your name
Lauren so
all our lawsuit requests both
compensatory and injunctive relief so I
think you know whatever and I think Dr
bettergo and others and we have put
together substantial monetary studies as
to the economic impact and burden not
just the loss of lives in Philadelphia
but the actual economic burden on the
city itself so we are happy to put that
forward and show that during Discovery
in order to get a something that can
come close to compensating us on a
monetary level but we will be seeking
both monetary and injunctive relief as
the mayor stated
I'm not going to comment on that but
okay that's we we usually don't get
noticed when people sue us either so
yes it has been filed
we we worked with the Giffords Law
Center and our police and our law
enforcement as to identifying which were
the suppliers you know at issue here in
Philadelphia
I cannot comment on that I would leave
it up to law enforcement if there's if
it's appropriate to comment on that if
not no comment
[Music]
I will leave that up to law enforcement
if they're in a position to comment on
that right now
yes I can answer that question uh I am
Michael Garvey I am the head of the PPD
crime Laboratory
um privately made Firearms which is
basically what we call all of these are
we have seen a large increase over the
last five years starting in 2019 we saw
95 per year
prior to that we didn't even count them
because there was less than five for the
three years prior to that
by 2020 we see an increase from 95 to
250 pmfs
by 2021 we jump up to 571.
575 and so far
to date for 2023 I know you heard 285
but from the time of us providing that
we are now up to 200 and 292.
these are firearms that when we receive
them crying guns which last year we saw
a total of
6269 of which
575 were privately made Firearms little
under 10 percent
but what I can also say is that
they account for they are the third in
terms of rank for the crime guns that we
see so the third most common crime of
gun that we see are pmfs
so the problem here is we're seeing
larger numbers of pmfs which prevent us
from doing the very thing that we have
to do once it's used in a crime is
figure out how did that firearm
get used in a crime
pmfs prevent that process by us not
being able to trace it to the first
purchaser and any sale after so when we
have these crime guns and they're the
only ones we're talking about here so
292 crime guns that we cannot Trace
any other questions on that before I
the first most common type is a is a
Glock the second is a Taurus and then
after that are the obviously the pmfs
uh I can talk about generally that yes
we are seeing crime guns being used by
younger people but I can't say uh for
the pmfs you know that this is the these
are the ages that you know use those
verse any others but we are seeing
crime guns in the hands of people
younger and younger
you're welcome
and just the other frightening thing
about these privately made Firearms is
not only are they not traceable because
of the without a serial number but you
can't magnetize them so you can bring
them into a public space walk through a
magnetometer and not trigger it
because I have faith
I have faith in the courts do the right
thing at some point faith in God and
Faith at our Law Department
we can't just sit on our hands I mean as
I said before every time counsel or the
administration comes up with some way to
control to influence the proliferation
of guns the state legislature in their
infinite lack of wisdom steps up and
stops US
so we're we run out of things we can do
until we figure out new things we can do
yes
I'm not a gun guy
they're polymer 80 and jsd supply
um
this has nothing to do with happened
Monday night
this has been in the works for I guess
you're more
yes
um we're happy to distribute a copy of
the filed complaint to anyone who would
like it but as you will see
um you know as a preview it is a very
detailed complaint it's over 60 pages
long and so it is
um you know it was extensive work with
the Giffords Law Firm Center uh the
hospitals firm and our in particular Law
Department our litigation chair Renee
Garcia our chief of affirmative and
special litigation Ben fields and the
divisional Lydia first who have been
really on the forefronts in all of our
creative affirmative litigation efforts
to try to as the mayor said try to
attack this epidemic of gun violence the
last way that we actually can so it is
very detailed it took a long time and so
that's why it took so long
right they're the ones based on the my
understanding is that the based on the
data and the research that we have done
those were the ones that were most
significant here in Philadelphia
that is my understanding but again
focusing just on this particular lawsuit
that's why we focused on them
I think yes I mean as I think
um director Garvey had sort of alluded
to and I'm sure as you have seen through
the different gun violence briefings
it's very hard because they're
unserialized to really put them together
there are some key components that are
very distinguishable to put these
particular manufacturers
um so that's um so we focused on those
and we're pretty confident that these
are the ones that we need to go forward
against in this lawsuit
well we hope not we hope to make the
necessary efforts and changes in the law
and behavior necessary through this
lawsuit and as the mayor said and all
the other litigations and
um
this is really a full court press
against this epidemic so we're hopeful
as the mayor said in all of these
different efforts that we will see a
change in that Supply
anymore in the lawsuit
anything else
so I'm Frank Van Order Deputy
Commissioner of Investigations so what I
can't tell you is and I'm not going to
get deep into the investigation but uh
from the shooting on Monday night the
defendant that the police stopped out
there uh that was eventually charged by
the district attorney had two Firearms
one was an AR-15 the other was a nine
millimeter we've confirmed through our
lab both of those weapons were privately
made firearms
both of them were PMX
so they're parted at 292 that we now
have in our possession
right well the the lab does an analysis
on them and they could tell yes they
don't have any markings they're not
traceable so if you wonder if he would
have dropped that weapon and got away we
had no way to trace that weapon back to
him
and
yes
privately made Firearms yeah
the analysis is still underway by the
lab we'll have more information
we have some forensic and examinations
that have to be done on those guns and
then we pass it over and they'll do the
Firearms examination so there's more
examination to be done
yeah I've seen all kinds of reports out
there what I could tell you is that we
can't comment on that any interaction or
statement that he may have given
all right
be good
[Music]